We have built a virtual, slow-motion camera,
where we can see photons, or light particles, moving
through space. Now you have seen Doc Edgerton's
pictures of a bullet through an apple.
But photons travel about a million times faster
than bullets. So our camera can see these photons,
or bullets of light, traveling through space.
We use a very regular pulsed light source
and a camera, that is not one camera, but an array
of five hundred sensors, each triggered at a
trillionth-of-a second-delay.
So, even though each of our sensors is slow, we
can still capture fast movie.
I'm standing next to our laboratory setup here.
This is our camera, objectives in the front here.
The body of the camera is much larger than what
you would expect from a regular camera,
like the one over here.
Our light source is a titanium-sapphire laser
that's over here, and emits a beam of very, very
short pulses, and those pulses are then directed to
the seam [pause] with these mirrors.
Now, our camera only sees one dimension
so it makes a fast movie, but it makes a fast movie
of one line of the scene only
And in order to fix that, we have these two
mirrors here. We look at the scene via these two
mirrors, and when we rotate this upper mirror here
we actually see different lines of the scene.
So, what's happening is, the camera keeps taking
images and we very slowly rotate this mirror
to scan our field of view across the entire scene.
And because all of our pulses look the same,
we can, in the end, go and combine all of these
images that we took to get one complete movie
of the scene.
Such a camera may be useful in medical imaging
in industrial or scientific use, and in the future
even for consumer photography.
In medical imaging, now we can do ultrasound with
light, because we can analyze how light will scatter
one-dimentionally inside the body.
In industrial imaging, one can use the scattered light
to analyze defects in materials.
And in consumer photography, we are always
fascinated with creating lighting effects that appear
to come from very sophisticated light sources.
But, because we can watch photons seemingly
moving through the space, we can analyze the
transport, the movement, of these photons and
create new photographs as if we had created
those expensive light sources in a studio.